congress is preparing for a new battle
after handing president trump the first
congressional defeat of his
presidency the republican-led senate
overrode
mr trump's veto of a massive defense
spending bill on
friday a similar measure passed in the
democrat-led
house this week meantime president trump
and president-elect biden are planning
visits to georgia on monday
ahead of that state's two crucial senate
runoff elections on tuesday
those results will determine which party
controls the senate for the next two
years
congress is set to certify mr biden's
electoral college win
this week but some republicans are
planning to challenge it
for more on all these developments in
what stands to be anything
but a quiet first week of 2021 in
washington we're joined by bob cusack
editor-in-chief
of the hill uh bob good morning to you
let me let me start with georgia with
control of the senate at stake
on tuesday what are you hearing
well what i'm hearing is republicans are
very nervous
they are the favorites or should be the
favorites in this race if you look at
the history
of statewide races in georgia though the
state has been changing
but overall democrats have a money
advantage they're not divided like
republicans on various issues like
election fraud and the stimulus checks
so
if you look at the polls if you believe
the polls this is a jump ball so this is
50 50 and the races are probably going
to go one way or the other because
people who are voting are going to vote
one way or the other not going to split
their ticket how much of an impact do
you think the president
uh calling these things the race illegal
and then of course he's going to be
there campaigning on monday we'll have
on those two candidates
oh i think it's significant and should
republicans
lose there's going to be a lot of second
guessing and a lot of fingers going to
be pointing at the president
because that doesn't help turnout uh in
the state when you're saying
when you're you're seeing the governor
and the president republican governor
and the president
at odds with one another and then
questions about whether the
the election is going to be valid that
hurts turnout and that hurts republicans
there's also the issue of the senate
blocking that two thousand dollar
stimulus check as well is there an
impact from that that we might see
uh significant i think uh john ossoff
who is facing off against
david perdue really seized on the 600
check saying it was pathetic
so this is the key issue going into the
election and and that's why
republicans are nervous and that's why
some republicans just wanted to pass the
two thousand dollar check
just to get the issue off the table
including uh former speaker newt
gingrich from georgia so
there are troubling signs here for
republicans but remember the history
does
favor the gop in the state um bob
congress is set to begin the process of
certifying
joe biden's win on wednesday senator
hawley
of missouri is the first and most
prominent to indicate that he's
going to take issue with that other
republicans
it appears will as well how long does
this process do you think take
jeff takes a really long time i mean
this is going to be at least
one two hour debate on the challenge of
one state it could be more than that
because more states
could be challenged so mo brooks who's a
republican from
alabama who's been spearheading this
effort
in the house says expect a very long day
and there could be turbulence because
there'll be rallies
if trump supporters are going to be in
town could be some violence
we're seeing here with a few weeks left
that the president has in office
a very complicated relationship with
those who at one point were very
supportive and now
not necessarily backing some of what the
president is calling
for how do you think that changes the
relationship with those republicans
moving forward in the relationship
within that party
well listen when i talk to some
republicans privately i mean they want
to move on they want to move on from
from president trump
and look to the future but but they
can't because
trump is still the leader of the party
he may run if he's healthy i think he
does run in 2024
and he's going to be active in primaries
and elections so
trump and the republican party are
married for now do not go silent into
that good night i guess bob cusack thank
you very much